mir nun zugeschaltet fdp chef christian
lindner guten abend herr lindner ja sie
haben gerade auch gehört zu forsch das
sind die worte der kanzlerin finden auch
sie dass an manchen orten in deutschland
die lockerungen zu forsch durchgesetzt
worden
nein frau würzbach das kann ich gar
nicht finden sondern ganz im gegenteil
habe ich sehr bedauert dass frau merkel
heute in ihrer regierungserklärung keine
klare strategie auf gezeigt hat wie es
uns besser gelingt den gesundheitsschutz
auch mit einem leben in freiheit
verbinden zu können das muss ja die
aufgabe sein im jetzigen zustand werden
wir nicht noch über monate oder gar
jahre aufrechterhalten können
tatsächlich ist frau merkel
zurückgefallen ein modus alles dass
menschen politiker vier
landesregierungen anders einschätzen als
sie wird als leichtfertig dargestellt
und das ist die falsche politik
ich habe respekt vor den einschätzungen
von frau merkel
aber es gibt immer auch alternativen
über die man nachdenken kann und bei der
strategie von frau merkel habe ich
inzwischen meine zweifel ob die
gewählten maßnahmen tatsächlich geeignet
und erforderlich sind um den
gesundheitsschutz zu dienen
was genau wäre denn ihre alternative ich
mache drei vorschläge erstens wir haben
ja viele verbote und einschränkungen von
denen es dann wieder ausnahmen gibt da
das öffnen dort darf es nicht mein
vorschlag ist wir ersetzen das durch
eine grundregel die grundregel muss
lauten wenn die hygiene gewährleistet
werden kann wenn die beschäftigten im
service masken tragen wenn die zahl der
menschen die zb in einem betrieb oder in
einen laden gehen wenn die zahl begrenzt
wird sodass abstände eingehalten werden
können dann soll man öffnen zweites
prinzip wenn es in kiel einen neuen
infektionsherd gibt warum muss dann ein
hotel in garmisch geschlossen bleiben
will sagen wir brauchen also eine
stärker regional differenzierte
herangehensweise an das virus dort wo es
viele infektionen
da muss man ganz offensichtlich das
öffentliche leben deutlich zurückfahren
vielleicht sogar noch deutlicher als
dies bislang getan haben aber dort wo es
wenig infektionsgeschehen ist da glaube
ich brauche mir das nicht und zum
dritten
wir müssen die möglichkeiten der
digitalisierung nutzen in der verwaltung
den schulen aber vor allen dingen auch
endlich mit einer app die infektionswege
nachvollziehbar macht aus einer anonymen
basis das wären bausteine für eine
alternative krisenstrategie die freiheit
und gesundheit verbindet stadt wie das
seiner frau merkel vorwerfen muss immer
noch gesundheit und freiheit
gegeneinander auszuspielen
das gegenargument gegen einiger ihrer
punkte ist sie riskieren damit viele
tote und ist so schwer dagegen dann was
zu sagen was es also ihre antwort auf ja
diese these dass man noch mehr tote
riskiert wenn man jetzt manche der
lockerungen oder erinnerungen die sie
gerade angesprochen haben durchsetzen
würde ja dass ein totschlagargument ein
rhetorischer trick denn es geht ja nicht
darum den gesundheitsschutz zu
reduzieren sondern im gegenteil den
gesundheitsschutz nur intelligenter zu
organisieren also mich überzeugt das
nicht dass man in geschäfte gehen kann
die 400 quadratmeter fläche haben aber
in einem geschäft mit 900 quadratmetern
da darf man nicht rein weil da ein
stellungskrieg höher ist das hat das
denn mit der grundfläche zu tun das
sagen übrigens auch epidemiologen wie
der professor krause den ich heute im
bundestag zitiert habe vom
helmholtz-zentrum für infektiologie in
braunschweig
er hat damals mal die regierung bei der
ehec krise beraten und der sagt jetzt
die ganzen ausnahmen und regeln
bürokratisch aber nicht erforderlich
entscheidend sind die hygiene konzepte
dass man sich nicht anstecken ich glaube
auch so eine einfache regel müssen wir
uns wieder verständigen ich mich noch
einmal zurückgehen auf die rede von der
kanzlerin die wir auch gerade gehört
haben mit den worten zu forsch und der
kritik wir haben uns gefragt wen hat sie
gemeint was denken sie welche
ministerpräsident sollte sich davon
angesprochen fühlen
ich denke insbesondere die länder
nordrhein-westfalen und rheinland-pfalz
waren angesprochen das wird man
zumindestens so auf den fluren
vielleicht auch teile
der politik die in schleswig holstein
gemacht wird zentral länder in denen
auch die fdp mit regierungsverantwortung
trägt man ja kein zufall sein denn in
der tat wir erhalten unter bestimmten
bedingungen stärkere öffnungen als frau
merkel für möglich nicht zurück in den
februar
aber der jetzige zustand hat so viele
folge wirken wenn ich das noch sagen
darf ob nutzbar
wir sind eben nicht mehr im märz das
gesundheitssystem hat fortschritte
gemacht haben wir mehr kapazitäten wir
alle haben kann in jene kurse absolviert
sind viel sensibler im alltag die
menschen werden fortwährend von der
politik gelobt wie solidarisch und
verantwortungsbewusst sie sind ja wenn
das ernst gemeint ist das lob an
solidarität und
verantwortungsbewusstsein können wir den
menschen auch mehr zu trauen und sich
selbst zu schützen etwa durch masken
wir haben auch insgesamt mehr
schutzausrüstung zur verfügung und
deshalb können wir jetzt auch andere
wege gehen als noch im märz das ist
nicht ein weniger an gesundheitsschutz
aber es ist der versuch in negativen
folgewirkungen der jetzigen politik zu
reduzieren die hat ja auch
gesundheitliche folgewirkungen ihre
kollegen von der blauen gruppe der der
welt bei springer haben heute ein arzt
zitiert der davon berichtet dass es
keine herzpatienten mehr gibt keinen
schlaganfall patienten mehr gibt
menschen mit auffälligen bauchschmerzen
die auf eine entzündung des blinddarms
hinweisen könnten die stellen sich in
den krankenhäusern nicht mehr vor
also da ist ebenfalls ein
gesundheitliches risiko durch die
bekämpfung von corona entstanden und
deshalb müssen wir zu einer abwägung
wieder kommen sondern wirtschaft gar
nicht zu sprechen
sie sagen also armin laschet und daniel
günther unter anderem waren damit
wahrscheinlich gemeint wir haben heute
aber morgen 3 wir haben bei anderen
ministerpräsident noch nachgefragt
genauer gesagt bei herrn kretschmann und
herrn söder die heute zusammen um bahnen
wollten da mal hören ob sie sich auch
angesprochen gefühlt haben und fühlen
sie sich angesprochen von der kritik der
kanzlerin
nein ist ein nein wäre könnte sie damit
meinen jedenfalls waren württemberg und
bayern sicher nicht
wir werden jetzt ja dann nachher in der
pressekonferenz noch mal sagen
heute geht es einfach darum
schulterschluss südschiene steht und
wenn man es so sagen kann
die vorsichtigen in deutschland die
zinsen jetzt dass man so eine kritik so
eine öffentliche kritik von angela
merkel gar nicht gewöhnt glauben sie es
gibt wirklich richtig streit hinter den
kulissen jetzt zwischen der kanzlerin
und dem ministerpräsidenten zumindest
manchen von ihnen das weiß ich nicht
aber ich wehre mich dagegen dass
diejenigen die zu anderen abwägungen
kommen unvorsichtig sind das ist ja so
etwas was versucht wird jeder der das
anders sieht als frau merkel oder herr
söder der sei automatisch unvorsichtig
als gäbe es nur die vorsicht einerseits
und leichtfertigkeit fahrlässigkeit
andererseits und dem widerspreche ich
dass diese alte politik die in
deutschland gemacht wird unter der
überschrift alternativlosigkeit das
haben wir schon mehrfach erlebt bei
schweren krisen unseres landes aber es
ist nicht alternativlos man muss immer
abwägen und im übrigen klar ich habe
verständnis dafür dass herr söder zu
anderen politischen entscheidungen kommt
als etwa in mecklenburg vorpommern
angezeigt sind weil in bayern noch sehr
viel mehr infektionsgeschehen ist
übrigens trotz der scharfen maßnahmen
von herrn söder ist da teilweise mehr
infektionsgeschehen als in anderen
bundesländern
also muss er anders darauf reagieren da
habe ich verständnis dafür aber die die
zu anderen abwägungen kommen können weil
das infektionsgeschehen anders ist weil
man dinge anders beurteilt wenn man auf
andere intelligente maßnahmen vielleicht
setzt denen darf man nicht den vorwurf
machen sie handelten leichtfertig und
das sage ich bin kein ministerpräsident
der cdu
das sage ich ausdrücklich auch um die da
genannten beispielsweise herrn darstellt
oder auch frau dreyer in rheinland-pfalz
einmal zu verteidigen die letzte frage
nicht nur an die politik sondern auch an
ganz deutschland gerichtet sagt angela
merkel ja mal wieder wir sollen uns an
die regeln halten denken sie die
kanzlerin ist zu streng mit uns allen
das heißt zu streng also das hört sich
an als sei sie in unserer
erziehungsberechtigte frau merkel eine
politische abwägung und der appell dass
wir uns verantwortungsbewusst im alltag
verhalten sollten den kann man doch nur
unterstreichen
aber was mich stört ist dieser dieses
auftreten der politik und auch der
bundesregierung als sei das was
verkündet wird die absolute wahrheit
wird zwar die bild zeitung hat sie heute
selber aufgezeigt was denn mit den
masken erst waren die masken ich
sinnvoll
dann ist ein zitat in der bild zeitung
heute zu finden von frau merkel die
masken seien potenzielle virenschleuder
dann plötzlich waren die masken eine
zumindest eine höflichkeit geste
dann wurde die maske zu einem dringenden
appell und jetzt ist die maske plötzlich
licht und das zeigt doch da wird das
sehr schnell die meinung verändert und
korrigiert jetzt geht es darum dass die
verdopplung zahl der gesamt infizierten
reduziert werden muss jetzt geht es um
die neue ansteckungskette also
fortwährend werden die einschätzungen
die prognosen und die grundlagen der
entscheidung verändert und das ist nicht
der vorwurf den ich mache man lernt dazu
dann verändert sich die einschätzen man
darf man aber auch nicht so auftreten
als würde man alleine nur wissen was
richtig ist und was falsch ist darüber
muss gerungen werden und da dürfen auch
politiker wie etwa armin laschet nicht
mundtot gemacht werden indem man den
eindruck erweckt gehandelten unmoralisch
weil sie tote in kauf nehmen wollten
oder weil sie das vorsichtsprinzip
nichtbeachten möchten vielen dank
christian lindner dass sie heute abend
hier bei uns in der sendung an und für
ihre einschätzung